all right and we are finally live the
last word with Laura Cognito
and he bounces - cheated the ninja low
Fitness action this morning getting you
all pumped up and hype for all this
great news we have a joke Society how
you doing bet crazy crazy times but
other than that how you been uh it's
been a it's been a rough week it
basically started after our last podcast
actually yeah picked up last word never
picked up the last of us which by the
way also not a v' easy game to play
through for a whole different amount of
scope of reasons but mmm it started
Friday and it honestly hasn't stopped
and if you guys don't know what we're
talking about basically allegations a
very inappropriate behavior it's the
nicest way I can phrase it without going
into details which we don't want to do
came out there about some very prominent
people it's a very brave individuals
ladies and there are some gentlemen with
their stories and stuff that came
forward as well and it has started just
a waterfall of people coming forward
telling stories about either people in
our community unfortunately which you
know we always say our community is one
of the best ones nobody's perfect were
were painfully learning and it started
to expand and it's kind of still going
yeah so I was like I even was gonna play
some on Friday night and then by the
time I got done do what I was doing sat
down I watched it start and it was
almost like watching a slow-motion train
wreck
I couldn't stop baby you got it
I believe you had a stream set up right
I was I was planning on playing last of
us that night and it didn't happen yeah
yeah I mean if I jump in I mean it's
been a rough it's been a rough weekend
it all started obviously this weekend
we're not gonna get into the gory
details of who wept obviously prominent
members you know in our community who
you know mean he have interacted with it
meant a lot of a lot of these people so
um you know it was very surprising and
and obviously you know again respect to
all the you know creators women who came
forward and told their stories and you
know I pretty much put a spotlight so
you know as the weekend continued and
you know like you said a perfect analogy
almost like a train record like you just
see this thing happening right before
your eyes and as it goes on and it
starts to expand outside the Destiny
community and more in the gaming and and
you know prime companies and and other
organizations and streaming platforms
and it just keeps going on and on and on
so you know at the end of the day it's
just one of those things where the way I
look at it this is very sad times
however the way I always look at things
like this is that sometimes the ugliness
needs to get exposed so that we can
clean house and recognize that you know
what you know I got a I got a home but
there's this corner of the room that has
this dirt that has this problem and I'm
saying that what that has been neglected
and I think at the end of the day you
know I think it really needed to happen
as much as it's overwhelming at times
because we've got to do better as a
community and I love that the title that
you picked for the thumbnail might be
excellent to each other we have to be
we've got to be better and this is it's
a watershed moment for the the community
and I'm saying gaming I know we talked
about you know obviously last time when
you know God the last podcast we had did
with me and on the George Floyd
situation had um had just popped off and
how sad and we all were you know so
again I always feel these are moments in
history where we use as a jump-off point
for change and hopefully that's what can
come out of this and um in reference to
the whole streamers and gaming community
and stuff like that what I hope now is a
lot of hard-working people who may not
get attention you may not be part of the
in-crowd or whatever get some light
shine on them for the hard work that
they do because we got to now promote
these people because they're all so
positive but there there are a ton of
still positive members in our community
so what
got man but all yes but it's been off oh
it's been a rough week well that's that
was some of the things and it's for me
it was I'm the wrong person to have
basically anything to say about anything
we've got on screen so the one above my
head blacklivesmatter we talked about
that before and that is protests are
still going on which is good they seem
to have gone more in a peaceful
direction I think the initial like bad
apples per se whatever you want to call
like it seems to have gone at least in a
good direction then word all this is
happening the middle of Pride Month
which is when it's not an easy thing for
anyone who basically just walks what a
lot of people would call a different
path but it's what they want to live and
they should be allowed to live it
equally and it's not an easy thing for
them to do and then to just tack this
one on top and the reason the teal
ribbon is up there it's the sexual
assault awareness color yeah so that's
the reason I did put that one up there
that's what it's for
a couple of the stories that I read like
just like Reiki man they they were
really really hard to read I mean
they're ones that people should read
because if it turns your stomach inside
out that's the right reaction cuz it's
awful I mean for me I just I
I can't I can't picture what some for
one the strengthen some of these people
have to go through what they did yeah
and still be who then still be the
decent people that they are keeping it
inside and then on the other side I
can't fathom what type of person does
some of the things and it's like some
were not specifically related to the
gaming community one I read was just
literally like a stepparent growing up
and that was right
one of the hardest because there was
nowhere for that person to go to go yeah
and it got worse between you know if
they got to be you know defensive or
anything you got taken out on a
different kid like another sibling so
then in turn they sit there and like to
protect that sibling bay take it more
and it's like you see movies about this
stuff but when it's it's a real person
describing this stuff and it's just
disgusting little painful and I cannot
imagine the mental state that somebody
has to go through for that it's it's
terrible and me as a white guy with a
relatively decent life I'm just sitting
here going I I can't say I'm sorry
enough and I feel like anything I do say
word was just like before like my words
feel so empty but it's like as you said
also as well this is the point where we
need to start having change and I'm I'm
no better than anybody else because I
sat there and watched like I've watched
you know a friend act out in a moment
and it was a group of us and none of the
guys said anything should have right
there should not hesitate just be like
hey stop that
that's crap don't do it and right there
and it's in it it applies to all of
these if it's a B I can't stand by
anymore
good boy can't just watch we can't just
be like it it should get resolved or
that looks terrible it's like no doesn't
matter who you are we all need to trend
Blake fight for that change right and I
think you nailed it because at the end
of date all three situations and
scenarios of what we have listed on a
thumbnail whenever there is abuse or god
forbid life loss you know I'm saying
like that should never be accepted there
should be a moral compass going on
inside so that if you can't tell that
person to stop then you need to
not only separate yourself from the
situation and get help to those that
need it you know saying because that
that's what it's just like we always
talked about empathy right it's empathy
and compassion and in just not and we
got again love the title we have to be
excellent to each other we have to treat
each other
correctly and that's how we're gonna get
through this as a community on all
fronts made it really comes down to it
human empathy bro you know so again I've
read a lot of these accounts somewhere a
little bit too much to take and it had a
desire you know effect and um you know
there's definitely a sensitivity now you
know there's definitely you know a moral
compass I think that has been awakened
of surprise of what has actually been
going on you know so on again I always
think situations like this as painful as
it is as tough as it is I think in the
long run it ends up being a good thing
that it happened because now we have the
awareness and now things can actually
change you know I'm saying again whether
it be you know BLM BLM excuse me you
know and people on you know losing their
lives against you know over police
brutality things of that nature you know
whether it be sexual assault victims you
know people who are suffering in silence
who have been a vegan abused by people
position and power whether it be our
LGBT community you know I'm saying again
people just allowing to live their lives
and love what they want to love and it's
no big deal we just you play video games
I play video that's a look at we you're
a gamer we're brothers off top euros is
I don't care about any of that stuff so
it's just one of those things like South
office a yeah good vibes man shout to me
I'm using his turn to yeah it's all
about the vines man it positive my
gaming is supposed to be a unifier and I
always get into this with people on
Twitter and it's like I don't care about
the console thing that's cool it's fun
like sports teams but at the end of the
day if we should not be beefing with
each other over you know saying that
stuff because this is the thing that we
share that keeps our mind off all the
negativity of the world so how could we
be beefing about it or using this as a
power advantage against other people
it's just yeah and hopefully for what I
will say
yeah the Destin community people is
hopeful is cleaning house pretty hard
which is good yeah but I will say it was
really good to see a lot of the
community just stand behind these women
and probably one of the toughest thing
that they've ever had to do
yeah to stand behind them and support
them and just say hey we're here for you
and it was just nice because that's one
of the hardest things typically is when
somebody chooses to speak out is how
they're how they are received right and
it's the fear of backlash fear of a
whole lot of things that they may face
and there are a lot of positivity just
to we're here for you we're so sorry all
those things were there and it was nice
to see that type of support fairly
quickly by such a large number of people
in that I think that alone gave other
people the s the stepping stone to be
like hey they were supported they came
out they told this hard story I think
this is actually a good place for me to
tell mine and that chain-reaction spread
a lot farther than anybody thought yeah
yeah I said but like it was huge
yeah the courage and the bravery of
ladies and some gentlemen as well some
were yeah I was like it's not just
ladies some guys as well and some people
like oh guys not it doesn't matter
either way it's like whether it being
mental whether it be physical it doesn't
matter you can get messed with no matter
kind of who you are because somebody can
screw with you mentally just as easily
as anything else and and that one can
hang longer yeah
and we just got it we got it we got to
be respectful we got we have to listen
you know I'm saying and I said to say
shout to the dog he's listening to
somebody's probably outside walking
right now that's it
it's fine it's fine but yeah I mean we
gotta be respectful we gotta listen and
um you know accountability you know
saying that dad has to happen so you
know hopefully now we can move forward
as a believe it was black wings yeah
time to cut out the cancer but old you
know that was still remaining yeah so
yeah it's one of those it's not a fun
topic to discuss we don't want to go
into specifics and we don't plan on it
but it is definitely something that
needs said and the reason we titled the
podcast this buggy has the excellent
message as well it's kind of why I put
it out there be excellent to each other
I think all of this together combines to
something that's really sad and it's the
idea of just human decency yeah and it's
really really sad in this day and age
that we have to talk about address and
try and hope for general human decency
when we are in times like this and
it's it seems simple to ask for but on
the other side its
yes yes yeah yeah it's like Mattie
Mattie says it ain't hard to be good to
each other and it shouldn't seems like
it shouldn't be it's like I know try and
be a decent individual I'm never gonna
claim to be perfect but I try and be
decent to my fellow human and I feel
like that's all we ask for but we can't
also it's the standing by we can't do
but it's just beat thumbing the Golden
Rule it's like do unto others you know
as you would like done unto you however
that's exactly right but some one of
them I read to is like mmm I can't
remember who said it but they're just
like if any of this stuff had happened
to a child of mine I don't have kids
have two dogs but if I had a child it's
like it would take every bone in my body
not to just lose my mind on set
individuals causing that type of trauma
pain scarring mental or physical any and
that type of stuff
rage Blake so if you ever need to think
about it and if you can't get to this
level didn't you probably need to go
away but yeah if if so if you don't
think this is an appropriate thing to
have you know actions towards one of
your children in down the road in the
future don't do it so that's like badly
yeah do others as you would have done
unto you Thank You crystal just yes so
it's no absolutely absolutely I think
last point I want to make is that on you
know reference community stuff you know
like I said community definitely you
know a Destin can be definitely took it
you know there there's no question you
know I'm saying and um you know for me
it's one of those things where you know
now we're doing this we see the action
by budgetary Swift they're not playing
and I love how they are reacting you
know I'm saying it's really cool to see
and um yeah I mean I just I just feel
that now maybe a bit of the the gating
and the power playing all that can
really come to it to an end and I
because now people's you know stuff is
content is getting removed it's getting
really are you know I'm saying so if you
want to engage in that kind of behavior
it's getting real tough to be an idiot
I'll just let y'all know right now this
climate it is real tough so it's time to
start maybe assessing yourself or
maybe even if it's not you who you
associate with because that's going to
be reflected on you and your brand you
know that it's rid really is so you got
to do a better job cuz again some of the
stories I read you know about certain
clans and and and things specific
moments I actually remember you know
watching people do their world's first
rain and get doxed and you know all this
hateful stuff that I'll either I
remember these things man it's really
really sad that you know there were
groups that were kind of doing this
stuff and exploiting people and um you
know that that one hit hard for me
because I've had personal experience
with you know those type of attacks and
stuff like that and I'm gonna tell you
right now it's a nightmare
it's a nightmare you don't want to wake
up you know living in that world and no
one deserves to go through that so
salute to at least that's why I say it
is good because it salute to that stuff
being exposed so now it can stop and
people can actually live in peace and
without harassment so you know that was
another another part that I got out of
it yep yeah Mike Abunda had a very nice
thing it's all of us it's like you me
everybody we have to find the courage to
step up when we see it happen and that's
how and that's hopefully what we can go
for is that we can take as you said
these moments and all all are in the
world of what's going on to be a step
for positive change to not stand by
anymore to step up when something bad
goes wrong to hopefully like people are
seeing this in this like steers them to
make those positive decisions just use
this as a time to change use this as a
time to self evaluate take a second look
at yourself in the mirror and say mmm
first off nobody's perfect there's I can
guarantee you know a new graphic here we
all got the you know L so it's
accountability cuz I seen some examples
of some people get called out I know and
they said you know what I don't
recollect that I did it but if I did I
was wrong I was sorry that should never
have happened you know and I actually
seen one possibly I seen a resolution
happen online yeah where the apology was
then accepted and then calls and and
people talking to each other
you know because again in your mind that
person's mind they make it think it's
all joking games but you really hurt
someone you think I'm saying and that's
the thing too so also communication is
key to cuz there's times listen lets me
go at it on it's about different thing
but like one thing I was at Yale you
know what let's pick up the phone
because the last thing I want to do it
get anything misconstrued and a lot of
problems should be gonna be solved you'd
be surprised by actually talking to each
other cuz two people can have a
recollection of events that's totally
different from each other even though
there's one truth and you can kind of
meet in the middle so that's another
thing too that's just my opinion that
that needs to happen I thought it was
actually positive that I saw online yeah
I was like in that one that I know it
was
on the smaller scale of things that yeah
but and that's why it's like some of the
stuff is kind of unforgivable yeah it's
like yeah I was like win at least
there's a but it's like the the eye eye
opening moments however they happen are
very important right now and some people
are saying it's like you know one person
in chat basically just saying hey I
might have to see about getting new Klan
not sure how they are this is it time to
check all the people you hang around
with I have hmm I've always had a fairly
small group of friends short list
generally not a ton because not a lot of
people that I've been around for a long
term have been as reliable or just you
know proved to be worth keeping in your
life and this is one of those points
where you need to check who who is in
your life
it's tough those are some of the hard
points especially if you've known
somebody for a while but it's like if
they're toxic if they're dragging you
down if you look and be like do I is is
this an actual friendship or is this
just like an abusive acquaintance I mean
there are certain ones just check who's
in your circle and it may be time to
clean up that circle and push some of
the unwanted people out of it it's a
fact I know bad day I've been around too
clean a band I used to have a ton ton of
quote on old friends and I think there's
a difference between real friends and
aquaintances you know I'm saying and you
have to separate them because you around
those people that brings you down that
bridge and I'm too old for negative
energy bro yeah I can't
I'm there's too much already going on in
life I all got tougher so one day
foolishness and negativity or abusing
others that's not gonna happen so yeah
after that's a great statement you have
to have to clean up house with your
friends and see who's in your circle you
know that's very important you have no
idea mm-hmm so let's take this moment
all together and just see if we can
change for the better
yes sir if we if we stick together if we
support each other and would call out
things that are bad and kick out the bad
apples hold onto the good ones and make
a positive place both in the gaming
communities that we're in both in the
larger communities that we interaction
act in and in real life just
people that are out there it's harder to
call things out I'm probably one of the
most non-confrontational people want to
try and get along I want to try and be
nice don't want to like be in the middle
of the action but it's like it's not
right to watch anything anymore so
that's exactly I got I gotta get out and
that's those like I got to get out of my
own box you just got to do it we all got
to improve we all got everyone me - I
mean I got again I have to keep a mind
of who I'm associated with because it
all reflects on me and and what I'm
trying to build and like you know we've
chapter saying I said we've been on this
positive fire tip I just can't have
negative energy I can't have people
pulling me down you know I I represent
some things too you know I got you know
how she Ireland Park has a website you
know I'm trying to do things as well and
you know I've always told people like
hey I mean I know people from back in
the day then I'm like hey if you
continue in these activities bro one of
them just called me it's funny yesterday
when unquote mean that I hadn't talked
to in a while and he actually is now in
the process of changing his life he's
just said cocci I understand why you you
kind of step away step away from me cuz
he knew he was he was too toxic you know
and he had to make changes in his life
and I said look it was never negative I
just couldn't be around especially for
what the mission I'm on he's totally
different from what you were on at that
time so it wasn't you know and we but
what's funny is years later we've we've
reconnected and I see some real changes
in his life so it's good to see well I
mean it's like we could sit there and
hash out different variations but we had
enemy we couldn't not talk about this as
broad as it got and as important as it
is hmm but see if we can move on to
something at least a little better a
little more positive at least a little
more of our joys of escapism
entertainment that we get into sometimes
yes sir this game of ours
what's yeah so what have you been up to
in this world of dusty this thing that
we do actually play sometimes despite
when you're staring at a screen and
things are going on but yeah yeah look
I've been playing at all
this way I am back in y'all you know I
was slacking the first week cuz I was
just kind of getting back into motions
and stuff like that took some time off
but this week I'll be going hard bro
I've been on I think I'm up to I went
from like you know a 10 20 I'm out 10:55
almost 10 60 isn't rocking um I've been
loving the grind
I'm not gonna lie you know doing me I
think the combination of the pinnacles
being regular activities I'm really
diggin that um I've been feeling loving
the the be weekly story be I am loving
the cradle going in there seeing what's
going off and I love it solo
actually I don't do it with her it's so
fun and challenging solo I think it adds
to the tension so I'll be loving that
listen to my Chris listen to what's
going on in there you know it almost
gives me a little shattered through and
I should I don't like a home ascendant
round vibe when you do those joint so
I've been doing um um roles umbral
focusing has been fun
charged with like builds have been fun
finally got my guillotine finally got my
arm what's the post the UM the
hard-hitting post and the new one uh
yeah it's cold denial but rocking it
wicked good game what's going on bro
yeah my bad go Dom if that yeah bass I
salute I was supposed to hit you up got
caught up with work and then I ended up
or PC Lake so Bob bad we're supposed to
get some Xbox on sound to sound out to
the Xbox crew but oh yeah man so it's
been fun it's been really fun I've
really been having a lot of fun with
this season and yeah and in fact lady
knocker has been talking strong man even
talking really strong and then that joy
you know I did a little bit kruseman
messing with some line up some bill oh
and I did a last thing I did my uh my
fault clean that was uh that was tough
mine's annoying right now but it's like
I'm hovering under but I probably need
to do another one but I got a me do some
guns I think it delete her I just
couldn't I some of the black armory guns
by bro no I kept mine sitar gays yeah I
was like oh God can really roll can do
um black couldn't do blast furnace bro I
wouldn't get nose like this Irwin's
I mean they're useful still like 85% off
so you know going crucial wouldn't be
like hey we got a new map with a buncha
range willed it pulses if they're in a
decent place I get killed my blast
furnace plenty so yeah if you got that
late you know chefs kiss god rules and
hold it there's no reason to get rid of
it from most of the game
could ya got curated yup Chris the other
cookie I got that is a couple one in the
rituals man I couldn't you know
reclusive getting touched yeah love
still love a cruise I'm rocking out to
the wheels fall off and I mean it's got
its regular crucible for a while I'm
sure yeah really I've been really loving
the season so forth it's just a basic
ground but I think it's really done
rapping to [ __ ] the combination of the
focusing the pinnacles being in the core
activities and um the story the there's
the the weekly story beast way we're
getting a little bit more and it's being
done well so it has to be new for me
what about you have how's your grind
been you know what's been going on shoe
it uh working more on pinnacles at this
point because I hit 1050 on two of mine
my hunter I barely touched but them two
characters have been going through
trying to do the weeklies especially
trying to work on leveling up the
prismatic precaster it's a little slower
means I haven't touched my hunter I know
if you've done all three you'd probably
be about done by now but I haven't done
all three so I'm a little behind
[Music]
although I am enjoying like the idea of
focusing like towards I want to go under
cold Nile and guillotine yes I mean
thought that's when you when you unlock
those and it's like I think it was
season past 50 when I got to get a 45
whenever I got the col de Nile and
guillotine both you could start known
for that one focused because yeah most
feels pretty good and then guillotine is
just melter with the right specs on it
raw with that what does that keen join
that kind when it put it proc its cork I
know it's called Keane the build name
when it's prop but the actual mod is
called something else lucid blade oh
that yeah if you go hard oh yeah
he said well even if you just you don't
even need loose and if you can just go
guillotine with
listen old you ever learn this whirlwind
and boss Beck based just about stuff you
you haven't seen greatness it to you
throw there that loosened blade you ever
thrown it all yet uh I think I did know
I was missing sidearms actually I
haven't done oh do this big throw that
on cuz all you need is that I think it's
like a four four piece one energy and
then you need another blue arm arc bot
to get the recharge rate as a secret
perk to proc in that in that thing go
into contact with that we it was like
three of us all in me with guillotines
looking like cloud for Final Fantasy
seven wrecking these day like I was
looking for the boss I said we add who
got a name good thing to have with those
swords he just bubble you just go down
good boy dog he said the fact that I
need to cry give it be for beads to it
in this week don't care be prom it's one
round come on come on dog do better so
was it was it this week was gambit or
was it last last week I thought I played
or is it this I know what I know the
grind you're talking about on that one
there was an option to do know this last
week reckoning was really fast
yes reckoning tear yes just go hunt down
the bosses it we call it week was was
this week's menagerie yeah and that was
I think Tassie said on one character he
had done in one run one run I had it
done in two and it seems to be based on
ability kills majors stuff like that
seemed to drop those so if you're
involved in killing the bosses the
majors using abilities if I'm just
shooting like red bars with a gun they
don't seem to drop as much but pretty
much all the other stuff seems to
elevate it up bro I have fun
oh god bring it this week I did you
raise bro I did classic Leviathan
finally got my actress on PC I got that
without a catalyst yeah we need to get
what the catalysts are the
the highest level you gotta do like the
yeah I got a prestige remember Z up I
gotta do the same thing we did on what
you call it we did of salvation we've
been raided I got a shop the attic bag
shout to scream it was me scream attic
shout the hans new member of our clan
real cool doings from actually from the
Texas area shout about
yes out the Heinz Heinz cattle in the
chat that's a nickname but yeah we had a
good screw and we I think for we just
got a 6-3 lfg cuz we miss wonderful what
it was in the building of course shot
the 14 course always you know I'm saying
in the Billy I get you in the last word
sir but um yeah baby we had a good
actually
alright I have to admit though raves is
when your friendship get tested with me
you is scare oh did of logical
acceleration yeah
just burn any final boss space okay with
him how clean it wasn't about the issues
people wasn't doing big things like you
you're the build team no you're supposed
to jump in what's going on and they like
the tether mechanics is still a little
touchy to someone yeah yeah so we had a
little issue took us a couple of runs
but we did get it because the property
issue was we were our dps was good as
far as melon I like a two-phase but um
it was just our coordination with
certain things other than there but I
love it man I so still don't divinity
Wow
yeah you got you need divinity mistake I
don't have to anything
thank I've finally got it jealous
finally got it yeah I got the vanity I
don't have anarchy honestly because I
just have a mouse courage that much so I
got AB run scourge it's this is the
season because they bumped up that
percentage so run it as much as I can
but I will definitely say Divinity's
little puzzles that you had to do those
fights
ah they were entertaining and when you
get to stuff like people
mm-hmm I got pulled through shout out to
Ares and his solid grouper Raiders I've
read it a couple times his home on
Garden butter smooth like butter smooth
to a point where I'm just like managing
the ads that um yes goodbye
easy peasy yeah seriously bra
I gotta get down with Tiger style man a
dumb boys they wanna shout the loose
from your clown like lose to for me
Ares you deal with him on the racer I
deal with a more the fever inside I like
lose but he gets me hype man it oh my
god so much fun to to rub PvP with those
guys and trials with those guys so much
fun continue so you say without the easy
peasy rated just just yeah and I was
like I think I've gone three times with
them because I think I did too clears
and then it was like specifically
divinity around he pulled me in for and
I appreciate and believe me I appreciate
that
because they know exactly what to do
where to go how to run it they've done
in plenty of times and then somebody was
like hey can you help us with a garden
run it's just another team and as you're
saying is a different feel the the wells
machine versus the the hiccups and bumps
along the way you're like I'm like dude
why are we wiping right now guys like
the other team has just knocked it out
like I'm handling my stuff you guys got
a handle expert and I'm just like yeah
yo the well-oiled great experiences are
what I would love a lot of people to
experience because you get to see cool
mechanics get to see like me the
teamwork meshing together you got the
little game that run down the hallways
we're managing the boss is shooting the
eyes you're like kind of sets a three
you come together line up bubble here
well here melt keep melting chase them
down I will say this though had a lot of
fun duel of I did over I got it a pre it
does feel it feels good being
overpowered coming up in a real plane
that feels good I'm like swords and all
this didn't exist all these builds it
the swords man they do change that brain
remember the dogs we do spores
we hold up got like one run of spores
but you can what's the rap I was like oh
my god you know the things we would do
it in that rate was callous didn't even
want to smoke one like literally maybe
two plates
we almost one plate of them you know
thing but to place was fun it really is
a great aesthetically I felt it should
have been a little bit more bosses but
if you look at the scope and how its
design how all the things connect to
each other like Leviathan is good and I
really really enjoyed it everyone that's
gonna think too about Leviathan you
picture spire
what the hell's the basement what is it
uh the one with the vex think yeah the
big trashcan I what's the second one
somebody eater eater eater of worlds yet
either eater inspire new Leviathan like
all of like the connection between so
that is when they say leviathans going
play baths could be one of that could be
bigger than like etz I can't I don't
know like there's a lot going on in
there for like textures and areas to
roam just like so much of that
underbelly and connection areas
especially just the regular trees in
there yeah Holmen area what's and crowns
ative and crap do you know is crazy
I haven't done I've done I've never done
Korea's like terrible or trauma or how
are you I say that wrong probably every
time I do not I finished that thing one
time okay I've done it at all I got to
do reduce I need to do spired I've
actually never done spire all right
spire prestige alone 8 I have a love a
prestige spire I don't like only because
I hate the weapon requirement
foolishness it's like yeah this week you
could only use those swords like how am
I supposed to hurt anybody with like
sidearms or something shoutout to a
known tester of weapons we tried a
six-person sidearm bills with like the 5
stack of sidearm like God cartridge or
whatever it is it's like some crazy well
I expect with charge of light mmm
hitting it into a damn thing to ribbon
oh yeah we tried that one
not enough definitely not enough on that
one
the only reason why I'm even thinking
about spot cuz you know how much to
sleep a fanboy I am so I got a water
it's like yeah they put that in the game
somewhere
they got to put it in the game like I'm
baking I'm betting I'm I'm praying a
minutes to the death years old go put
that on my goals yeah go go that is one
of these raids right
no one's gonna run either the ones run
inspired like that please if this we
know they're being removed please put
them in the loop OOP late I feel like
they've I know people are gonna be like
ah but I went through the prestige fire
20 times to get this thing it's like
it's been out for three years maybe it
belongs in like you know master night
falls maybe it's in a certain place like
that or you still have to challenge to
get to it but they they have to bring
some of those Telesto and sleeper are
both leap eater of worlds inspire and
then I need to finish see I will do like
press these Leviathan that's not so bad
you know your little challenge
personally I was like and that for a
curious I just need a people a group of
people who want to do it but like the
other two I've heard not the favorite
yeah no actually people like either I'll
be eyes say you've never done either at
all no I've done even know people like
eater okay yeah that I know people are
like it's one of the coolest ones they
enjoy that way fires just spires the one
thought is that I don't like that that
green ball thing you gotta run with the
ball and uh you know say it's just the
boss mechanic is a bit weird it's I
don't know I just don't feel like the
really each raid I feel has a rhythm
right each raid I feel has a flow
generally of what needs to be done I
don't never felt spires and counters
were fun like I never said this is fun
like I felt eater with fun cooking the
little cranium things and going around
that's fun you know I think each raid
has you know something fun about I love
Leviathan with the plates I mean even
their little American ninja moment it's
kind of silly but fun in a way you're
going to me you know who's gonna make
the jump and that kind of stuff and um
yeah I just feel a Moses scourge he's
got you out a few mumbles Angelo spiral
movement inside you got the metal gear
thing you know um I don't know it's just
something about spire that annoys me I
don't know what it is there's a lot of
people that don't like it so you're not
alone yeah mmm-hmm but shout out the
scare off or picking spire is the best
his best music
number one read music uh he's got spire
number one he's got spire that he's got
um my joint I was Fred I had to hit him
up idea he's got a last wish escape from
the heart dad
that one's gonna escape with never evens
hard that's a joy I go crazy when that
becomes on yeah gambit has a variation
of it when you play game it variation of
that be wait before you start but that's
not the beat the beat is actually when
you fight your own Chi and when you
fight um when you escape with the heart
Dan is the great I and then he I go fry
you know anyway he did though
what he did I gotta give it up the Kings
fall you know I nothing for it just for
what you know yeah I go for I forgot to
have that yo that's um that's boss music
yeah when Oryx comes out in here that is
that's the boss fight I would say like
really it's probably that scale but Oryx
is almost like the biggest like scale
and severely importance of a loss that
we fought I mean we fought we fought
solve in a story mission killed him in a
story mission now is definitely not
enough justice for a I've got a one gun
but yeah the ascendant realm version of
Oryx know that that was justified oh it
was so good so good love love that joint
man big-time pizza
coyotes like worm got killed with a
scout rifle let's go yeah that was
that's it's again that's the to say the
least
that was not a shining moment of like
hey these are warm guns hey I just shot
him with a cue could have done the same
thing with a sign if we had him at the
time now yeah I'm with you bro unless
you mm-hmm yes like there's one of
them's yeah written the same thing
actually Dakota
so Dakota's asking a couple things and
that's one of those things you think
about Leviathan and this kind of ties
back into how I wanted to ask you to see
how you think this is all gonna go down
so we've been on tayo for three weeks
with the pyramid shippi public event
contact get a little they say this the
pyramid scale has arrived which i think
is funny because it's like balances
perfectly on that point three weeks here
we got the three story missions I got
the triumph that you've like you've seen
all three versions of the yeah whatever
it is so we've seen the three which
honestly the fact that we got like
they're basically three legit story
missions like the arena's are different
you go through the tree but then you get
into the ascendant realm each one's got
its own unique spin to it you're there
for a little while if you do I'm solo
they can be a bit of a challenge man
like their loved one is so much fun and
much fun I mean the fact that we got
like three like you could make those
strikes you could straight-up make any
of those things strikes and I would have
some fun in there because you got the
you know get the enemies to kill the
spawns the damage you'll do to the
Shrieker shut it down I mean sabbith une
song is leaving but you got literally
three versions of it right here fighting
Street crews every time yo that one's
cool but so now the question is about
this season for TAS he actually had a
good video he's like I kind of beat the
season he got to season past 100 so I am
in his grind he's also been you know
working on umbrellas and you if you play
enough you're Gumbel's just like fall
you get them giggles oh I'm Rosa calm
hmm so if you start like you know focus
on a couple here don't focus them all
watch that currency cuz it's not that
comedy you're gonna burn through it but
you got you know you're um Broyles you
start to get everybody wants like a good
cold denial a good guillotine a good
whatever the arc sword is I can't
remember it either
um yeah it's flowing it's the beauty and
then the other one yeah somebody help me
out here he's got a couple cool swords
you got a couple but he said he's like I
kind of got my what imitations
plantations out kept you but so you've
got but again you've only got really
you've got the six new ones this time
around you've got some other ones people
like you know if you get a feeding
frenzy multi kill Kip truth-teller
it's kind of a god role that's a beast
little cool
so I mean there are some to go for but
you start to get some decent roles while
are you grind up and depending on how
much you play we've seen the three story
missions we're gonna probably get
another cup
next week is probably gonna be tightened
I was wondering if is this week cuz like
to irritation but if you guys didn't
know the season is like fifteen weeks
long
we still have 90 days left in the season
now or a couple days ago I think it
reset so mmm it's a long one yes sir so
we've got Titan maybe next because
that's the only other achievement we've
got so much my assumption why it's next
probably three weeks there maybe three
weeks on Mars maybe three weeks on
Mercury I think Leviathan is just gonna
like drive out of the solar system at
some point I don't think there's gonna
be a pyramid ship and live I don't think
I think Leviathan is just as big as the
pyramids if not bigger and could swallow
one there's a lot of them but still if
it's 3 3 3 and 3 just the repetition of
the stories and it does seem like there
are 50 there's 14 triumphs with Eris
because we had eight show last week we
had white we had can't remember the
first one still but we had three but
there's 14 so there's like maybe a
one-week buffer in there where it's like
you know right before we switch to
beyond light hmm so three weeks late so
we've seen most of what we're gonna see
potentially potentially I know so now
the things that we do spoiler warning we
have potentially to exotic quests yes
one which is lengthy I'm gonna be honest
from what I heard we had Jar von he said
there's like 22 steps to it some are
potentially probably gonna be time gated
I would imagine on that one as well hmm
we have the one that has been teased
this is not spoilers because Bungie
tweeted this one out the room rest
effigy this is the trace right the avoid
tracer it makes the little black holes
and then the relics that you can pick up
and go dunk at an enemy have you seen
that you actually missed out on those
yeah I didn't see to remind me after and
I'll tweet it just give it to you but
basically it's a tracer Apple win the
trace wife will kill somebody I don't
know if it's every time or if it's a
chance that it will it made this little
like kind of looking void orb thing you
see the hundred pick it up jump and then
basically slam like almost like a riff
slam but he slams it on an ogre
the ogre interesting so it's like you
make this little relic and then it's
this like little bomb you can go over
run around with and dunk and use
somewhere else so then actually like
finish your dunk Oh
I mean basically just likes kind of like
oh just kind of like slam it into the
ground and it's like a little bomb so
you're like you you have a gun that
kills things that makes little bombs
from like their little black holes you
know you you made the little singularity
run around and throw the singularity
kill somebody or dunk he he slammed it
on the ground I don't know if you have
to slam or throw that one looks really
cool that'll be a quest so we have to
exotic quests potentially I know the
other one that hasn't been teased but
it's been data mined so there are two
but again we also have the idea that
planets are gonna start to go away how
are they gonna play those out is it
gonna be the final week we're like hey
everybody get off of these planets we
gotta go save Sloane and Vance and I
heard things no I don't I don't know if
you this what I know but I don't I'm not
gonna spoil it but is there something
related to evacuation
yeah so you know you've heard things -
I've heard things so the idea is at some
point potentially these planets were
we're not going to have in the fall
get the hell out yeah so that's got to
transpire I don't know if it's like you
know last few weeks it starts trickling
off one by one all the insanity happens
you gotta go at least do each quest to
see a little right so it seems like
there's potential towards the end of the
season for big stuff to happen couple
exotic quests in the middle and then it
seems like this is your time to start
checking every box because we're gonna
have moments of triumph and Soulstice of
heroes which could be fun if they don't
screw the armor up like yes so years
yeah the funny thing is I still have my
warlock armor package of Soulstice still
to you too I couldn't I couldn't never
pick it up for that grind I was like oh
you still have the oh I haven't sitting
at the gunsmith why are you serious I
just like I haven't picked it up you up
maybe maybe y'all see if I just I don't
hey if I picked it up now listed be
higher light were you disgusted will you
well no I got to take one
I got a tight one and then I basically
just was like I'm not like I'm not gonna
infuse every single thing those like for
whatever reason I'm just like I didn't
pick this up whenever but I just had no
I have no reason to pick it up I guess
so I'm trusting you sorry
yeah but does he have like gunsmith he's
like boycotting this I haven't for like
my tightened I just haven't ever picked
it I I mostly play my Titan honestly I
looked at my okay playtime it's like a
thousand on my Titan hours like 500 on
the warlock the hunters like 150 my [ __ ]
is so neglected I get it just interested
I've never seen you like leave something
just yeah it's like I just seemed like I
could pick it up but what's the point
usually it's more just like I have
nowhere to put it half the time when I
get there so I've only been cleaning up
bulky stuff yeah now the truth comes I
mean that's everybody who watching this
knows it's an issue fine yes yes the
hoarder you like the
Oh can't leave hey anything I have dogs
I'm not a cat person
gotta respect at least it's dogs and not
cats come on sorry if you like cats
we give you like cats totally have fun
my friends to do but I'm a dog person
with the cat profile pic she got cheetah
mm-hmm let that rock okay continue
yeah I'm pretty sure a cheetah could
kick the crap out of most dogs too
yeah that's a fact that's a fact
there's nothing will catch it and when
it gets there it's still a African cat
that can kick the crap of the most
things we have like we've seen the three
the end potentially could be crazy the
middle is it's not gonna be it does if
it's anything like this week I will say
this week was pretty light we're like
hey are we getting tightened no we
didn't we got the one story and then
you're like it's kind of this is the
matin I mean this is the summer
maintenance we disgusting I'm not no I'm
not disgust don't put words in my mouth
detail don't put words in my mouth are
you saying this is mundane content oh
yeah it's just what we apply I'm saying
small before September mmm new order -
honestly I'm completely fine with it
because I want to play Last of Us ghost
of Tsushima death stranding I don't know
if I'll get to origami King on paper
mario
seems fun no like there's enough games
that i'm like if the summers lighter ii
that light bro like you are let's just
say you are blazing let's just say that
this is not that light i know i'm not
saying there's not stuff that i need to
do it's like if i tried to raid and do
anarchy like three characters like each
week and if I was gonna do other things
there's stuff that I could be doing I'm
just saying for for new stuff like this
week I guess just kind of hit cuz it was
just like I saw Tassie's video and then
I saw the one story and it was like we
don't have a new planet yet so I was
like his
just it's kind of I'm not saying it
hasn't been fun contact but honestly
it's a hell of a fun public event I
really like it's probably one of the
best and I think public events because
gambit gives a little bit of fun please
please pick up the triangles please it's
like people are avoiding them like
they're gonna get sick like go for the
triangle ladies thanks not that hard but
you like how it's got the mechanics of
like hey you got the blooms with a
little champion guy off the side you've
got the did the taken come in you gotta
open the bank back Lake oddly somehow it
actually is probably I mean yeah I think
Danno says it 12 weeks from now maybe
less fun but I will say like I've done
it a few weeks in a row and I haven't
burned it out too hard I haven't just
like grinded contact for hours right but
generally the times that I do need to go
through the couple times to get the
weekly Quest on and stuff like that and
I think it's like it's a good a good mix
of mechanics and ads but we're not
throwing balls thank god yes yeah yeah
so I think that's been good the story
missions have been awesome like all
three shout out because they basically
just made three whole story missions for
a season suit I know I know that's why
I'm like I'm not saying it's not all of
this stuff is quality stuff and it's
like and we're gonna be but it's like
when you do them for the fourth row
tation come twelve week like nine or ten
weeks all go so you're worried about
down the road if this exact pattern yes
if it is like okay so we'll go three
weeks on Titan contact contact contact
and we'll do three story the same three
story missions again just different
words for Maris three here three here
it's that it's and again for a season
some people may play sporadically here
not see everything and it honestly is
probably a good amount of stuff for a
lot of people who don't get to play that
often for those you me who burns them a
little faster will see it a little more
frequently so it may feel a bit
repetitive but for the casual player
dude this is a hell of a great season
yeah the prismatic remaster I will say
the prismatic recast sir currency wise
is really stingy though as much as like
as much time as you can put in
there is no way to make that go faster
indoors are some of the layer that is
specific that specifically blocked but
yeah that is hearing so hard it's the
two weeklies that's it yeah you have one
character it's gonna take you a long
time it's gonna take you most of the
season consistently playing mmm it's
late I mean I think Tassie said he did
it in three weeks with three characters
so it's like 18
forget it enough for it was like mmm
it's gonna take you like nine weeks if
you got one character to go through so
it's like it's not gonna be a short
process right matter of fact I mean we
do have to see um if they besides the
weekly if they introduce any other way
to get that material I've got what it's
called altered so I'm Afghan what's go
but um yeah yeah if you set out a facial
yeah I see what you're saying new right
yeah I mean it's definitely artificial
game extension there's no question it's
definitely it's definitely a time gate
because at the end of the day it's like
you can only get this certain amount of
digging and again unfortunately that is
the nature of seasonal content you know
I'm saying they have to keep you coming
back week the week it's not going to be
monstrous all I'm saying is it just came
out of season and work on night and day
I don't worry here no lip chat we just
came off the worse I this is refreshing
that I'm getting to do something that at
least is meaningful that has some story
beats and it's actually enjoyable to
play nothing that's all I'm saying like
is it you know God's gift today no I'm
not going there but it's definitely a
better version of the seasonal model so
far it's kind of what I'm getting at so
you know we'll see and they grow and the
end come oh man
I I know I know oh it's going it's going
you haven't touched it at all I'm shot
out - job of calling out my editor and
chief of Lords gave me that shoutout to
josh reading AKA ancient ancient of
frost AKA scimitar prime or I'm calling
you out bro I am being a real friend I
want to play this prophecy dungeon soul
bear and this man is begged me to do
this dungeon with him for the first time
so we could go in blind and I'll get
there are most likely sinister or Aries
and then I'll do it because I am hearing
this thing is a myth I'm getting mad
I'll watch khakis videos and I see him
has footage in the back and you're like
close close I gotta stop watching your
video babble like this looks mad fun I'm
supposed to be doing this slow yeah I
got it looks gorgeous I love the this
Steve question though someone brought
this to my attention one how you feel
um someone said to me I'm disgusted that
the prophecy dungeon starting location
is in the tower
as opposed to its own location on the
map how do you feel
there's a reason it's there okay I was
like nuts literally why one it's free
for everyone so it's a place everyone
has access to and there's a reason it's
in the tower
this isn't spoiling anything you shut
out the hands it's a guy I was gonna
call you out but you jump did actually
heads Gretel itself bro
he said I'll do what you feel I'll just
beat my butt yeah it was you it was you
he was be fooled because you shot that
he's doing to do to I love pockets clean
oh so he goes yo he literally takes his
hunter right we're in what's that that
the annex he's a [ __ ] I wanna show you
something so he's like if you look at
the position of the figure the privacy
to map it should be he's like hopping
he's climbing she scaling to I know it
was just on the dislike it's supposed to
be here he was really disgusted by this
so I understand the story interaction
but I will tell you having to go to
shattered throne manually yeah in the
Harbinger seclude or wherever the hell
that thing's located through a portal or
director go if I want to play an
activity it's fine now if the first time
you had to go to the dungeon yet to go
roam through the back of the drifters
area and see like an area and you enter
it the first time maybe but from that
point forward director same thing with
the for just no one wants to drive to a
forge every time yeah oh yeah that was
annoying I'm gonna same idea nobody
playing specific if you want to play an
activity go watch it for more because if
you have a higher team everybody walked
out everybody ready
and you gotta turn into a tower which
takes long enough as it is so like I
understand the gameplay design reasons
why it's same director node in the tower
okay so my question is does it without
spoiling is it tied in nice when you
start it know why you'll know it is okay
cool that's all I'm gonna say you'll
know what it is where it is it's going
down this week my shout out again shout
the agent of frauds Josh read and bro
happening you better be there on
Saturday cuz I'm doing this ray if
you're not dead not
Darwyn I want to play and I need a pic I
miss our pinnacles every week because
you at least if you need armor go do pit
of heresy oh yeah because that's a
guarantee
yeah but nice hit bugs the living hell
out of me but those damn rules still
suck ass
sorry language were an hour in though
and I'm getting mad you know they keep
giving me the damn class item dude I got
I got four in a row from my pillow from
yo I'm disgusting I'm like can I say
something besides a damn good and then
what's pissing me off is isn't it that
isn't it a 1260 I mean isn't it um
that's new pinnacle
no but I meant to oh the power level oh
yeah that's high press : cuz that shadow
keep right and shadow keepers shadow
keep not garden yeah yeah it is weird I
I guess they'll do it specifically
garden of salvation has the shadow keep
emblem on it garden gear like garden of
salvation gear doesn't have a different
icon right then shadow didn't but if you
get like blasphemer that's not coming
forward but if you get any raid weapon
that I can't think of from garden of
salvation for example those are so the
rate stuff is the raid stuff is coming
forward it's going to season 14 mmm I
think is the number I saw its in a swab
someone yeah okay okay and the thing is
with Leviathan just to clarify and I'm
doing it the armor is going forward
right Nathan's not nothing in Leviathan
comes forward I don't read last wish and
garden only really well the violins
leaving why would they keep that I just
want the armor for the aesthetic piece
the armor may you may be able to turn
that need of ornaments you may be
something with that but now that you're
not gonna be infuse is going check can
we confirm it's not all raid armor it is
last wish in garden that's been stated
real clear ornamental 0.2 so basically
all the other raid armor is not going
forward it would say correct which is
why most people tend to think there's
gonna be three raids
last wish garden and deep stone crypt
problem
whatever it's called and then though he
says the helmet reading a stop at 1060
no he's right about a power level yeah
he's right about so yeah that's what I
mean it's not going any farther so okay
now last mission garden had a little bug
where I think that light level was
showing wrong but that will be going
forward right so season 14 they
clarified that one but the other shades
they're all in case you might think I
got no problem with the court but rate
Alma is unique make that in order me
something oh that's a big if you want it
or work on earning it right now and then
you hopefully can turn it into Universal
ornaments with whatever they do in the
fall that's the well there
that's literally what I'm doing
literally so again I call the armor
looks hot but you say Oh does vault
space is gonna be rough going in oh yeah
yeah crystal says Luke said they're
going to reissue it before they leave
Reef you what yeah be clear crystal we
gotta make sure transmog facts black
wings transmog yes I agree
whiskey just kickin the [ __ ] when you
get a 60 Plus that Alma for a hunter
from the castor it has 10 pleasures
effects yeah there's the questionable
rolls the braids are my strength okay
I haven't seen that we need confirmation
y'all need confirmation cuz they may
bring Leviathan back at some point and
do it that way or hmm I I don't know I'm
gonna bring your vault of glass armored
floor no mostly no but anyway that's
weirdness Lake so I mean we do have
stuff with the only two things we know
on the dam director are mmm you know
it's also Civ heroes and moments of
triumph right which moments is just
gonna be how many boxes have you checked
and how many more do you need to check
right probably when that launches is
when if it's like hey moments of triumph
go do everything I really hope there's
not a flawless cuz I'm screwed if there
is yeah
[Music]
as I have lover
what did we need to Bertram's moment
need to have that Armour in collection
or oh I agree
yeah and that's that's kind of there's
quite a few questions when it come to
the fall a lot of things people want
answers to how transmog is going to work
is it something like I have the piece of
armor I do set tasks I get one
consumable you know like okay use it on
this and I turn it into an ornament
forever like we don't know how that's
gonna work or is it just like as you
said can you go into the collections and
be like there's an option you have this
one currency hold down this if you want
to use currency to make ornament like
that clarification I totally agree we
would we would be best you got her to
have that information
we definitely need clarity that's a fact
mm-hmm yep so I just was kind of like
I've enjoyed the season so far I've been
distracted with the last of us and uh
like trying to go between and my air
conditioner being you know a rather
having a couple rough day is there yes
Lou to the AC it's absolute insanity
yeah if I didn't have a scene here just
be like just like sweating in here it'd
just be bad
so
[Music]
just kind of
I don't know what else I know the season
has potential to end really well for you
ungrateful person ungracious on this man
just came off the work it has the nerve
the audacity to already it's our facial
expression I know not to take you
seriously so give me our tech guys
deserve you do not know what you just
came from me boxes did you not realize
the suffering you went through and
already after Bungie done bless you with
this great grind and here you are
looking down a road ready to complain
you can't even finish it without
laughing like public event yeah we got
one but honestly it's probably one of my
favorites story missions we got three of
them yeah we may see them in the loop
but I still enjoyed them all if you do
them solo they're a bit of a challenge
they're cool I enjoyed all three
travelers doing the air is what said
that Jim cherish dropped about the
traveler you know say hello German she
was about the arm high I feel like the
traveler is the daughters to say that
the traveler is shielding us yeah we're
supposed to exile one yeah yeah bro she
drop it that's life he would be a
prequel now that's the point of where
it's interesting because Sabbath hoon is
2021 we know that which Queen is then
but we're getting wrong Sabbath UN's I
like apparently and there's my guess is
the ruinous effigy because it actually
can black hold those things he is how
they're gonna actually get killed so he
probably happened to do that quest and
then run around and pick up all those is
my guess I could be wrong mmm-hmm you
think it's gonna be like a wish ender
situation where we got a problem
go around Popham get something hmm
remember how wishing they had the arm
okay Kevin got it yep what Apple
happened he said additionally all armor
from all other destination two raids
will be updated retro at retro actively
with the season of arrivals watermarks
will have a season 14 max power levels I
haven't seen it did not Kevin I must
have missed it so good so good but now
remember cuz I was like yo that's why I
was like wow am i doing it but and then
I remember reading like yeah I'm get cuz
I got man I like that
the Leviathan say at least a warlock who
that's clean bro
that's clean little Howard the way the
goal and I have to put a little red
shader on your gold and your said again
you're just new monarchy all over again
I don't know I'm talking about the white
gold I know I'm just saying white gold
and purple if you get a little red
shader on the way yep mm-hmm
apparently everybody needs to reign
constantly all the time fill up your
vault with armor don't care about your
weapons to lead them all don't over
these flat safe what's hazing it he said
yo we just had this talk he chest
cleaned out like I know need all his
race mmm and this is the stuff through
some people this honestly is a prime
example of why some of this stuff like
the average person and I'm gonna go 8020
there might be 20% of you that follow
Bungie on Twitter the watch Padres like
this that watch YouTube videos most
people don't all right don't like most
people my brother's kids for example
they just play they have no idea what
works what depending they don't know
what is honestly going to stay around so
it's like hey is this raid cool maybe it
was even misinformed there for a minute
yeah so sorry we don't know yeah I don't
know if there's a bike I know if you're
into a game it's probably good if you
follow stuff but also some of these
things like Bungie hasn't been that
they've put the like raid stuff out
there and things but it's not that clear
everywhere right they've been in it you
know just like for the
like we're aware cuz we're neck-deep in
this stuff but for the actual person you
know it's like hey there's this thing
sunset is coming here's this weapon
value this is how long it's gonna last
like for the Everett person like just
probably logged into the season be like
oh those numbers are new well those are
different
what are those mean and if you don't go
search it out the game doesn't tell you
right no that's a fact
I ended offense the only thing I would
say is that I think we're gonna get all
of that right before the September pre
hype you know I'm saying kind of thing
they're gonna do the rollouts I did you
notice that period this is what a fun
part of this is what I love doing this
show but it's like a they do it just
before it starts rolling out is that too
little too late for information on
what's gonna come forward yeah for
what's gonna come forward how Sun
setting works like the information for
the casual person like that more just
like they'll have like tool pop-ups and
stuff like that would be like what if
you hovered over infusion or if you
logged into the game or if there was
just a section of like some pointers for
like hey explanation of like just oh
yeah we know that'd be terrible with
yeah this is just some more in gear
communication about Agron literally some
of this stuff to say hey all raid armor
is gonna be this you talking in game in
game communication that's that's all I'm
askin that's always been there kill easy
oh they they just they don't do a good
job of the new player on I call it
onboarding like they don't do a good job
but you want you slice people Oh bro and
I guess shout out to do like like not
telling you not like you there's just so
many people to talk to who did we have
when I said that I'm gonna I've never
done it but I think he actually made one
separate account to go through an
experience it was like dude it's just
you log in then yeah talk to everybody
that's what say yeah what yeah everybody
go to everything you're like what do i
do what do i do next and that that's the
question they there's not that
consistency and now I did remember I
think maybe to 12 ago or right around
what is it the dawn joint the beyond
light joint
they said they recognized it and they're
working on something better or I believe
it was Luke that said it's something
better for new players come September
cuz home
prove it they got they got to improve
now well I mean the other pieces like
the red red war campaign you're losing
hair like two of the planets involved in
the red war campaign basically all of
year one they're just going take it
there they're literally picking up and
taking that out of the game so you got
first gun war mind gone red war and Dawn
those campaigns won't be there right and
they actually kind of say - they're
going you know a little bit back to the
stranger story of the opening mission
with the cosmodrome that they now
cosmodromes gonna be coming back first
for just new light players in the fall
so they're gonna do another push for
like hey you want to try destiny free
now if you come back and see many
Cosmodrome stranger a little bit there
then you kind of get into it because now
the strangers tied into the story so
they're actually connecting the start of
d1 to where we are indeed - six years
later 700 need what number that is
into the seventh year so they are
supposed to make that kind of a
different feel of new light because
they're literally taking that first year
of d2 note right facts facts which is
weird because obviously like out like
that would say that second mission in um
red war just the same automatic music
romantic and just lights gone you're
walking that's great looks great
literally the weight of the world is
like it's so it was a cool feeling
mission I was like absolutely well done
I was a good it was a good campaign what
what we complained about Vennela d2 one
thing we gotta say the Gaul story
missions were cool I thought that whole
leading up was really really quite I
enjoyed it
you had to a little cutscene you got him
in the arm the little what's-his-face
that I've got the guys name the little
consort guy he ends up killing Gaul oh
my god yeah I love the I it felt like
vintage it felt like vintage bungee from
the Halo days when you would play a
stage then you would get this background
similar cinema maybe of what the enemy
is doing right and I just loved it he
transitioned out and then we killed
speakers I was all about
as well Cyrus hey kid give me a rapier
that's the aside I gotta totally Jam got
30 Jam him false prophet oh and then
like Dakota had a good point what's
gonna be free
hmm cuz they're getting rid of the free
stuff right now
the point two point three ninety-nine
what's what's new new new light yeah cuz
I mean I could go do your one raids you
could go do quite it there's a lot of
store there's a lot of story missions
they say in forsaken I don't know
that's that means it's gotta be forsaken
make for Sega's time doesn't mean
tangled Shore and dreaming cities still
there that's that whole campaign and
that's not easy in the big swell
encompass stories that's a pretty good
story in and of itself do you think
that's the light yeah it's got it cuz I
mean read like you're one is that's out
so you got shadow keep you've got
forsaken as your main to obviously the
new stuffs gonna be separate
but yeah it's like they gotta give that
new light because new light was big they
don't want to shrink that too small and
forsaken is gonna be again forsaken was
a year - you've had forsaken for two
years so again people like oh no why are
you giving it for free cuz it's two
years old so new time was it fits
there's still some courses yes it would
be it probably will be free in the fall
mmm okay great I mean I have to assume
that they're because they still the new
light the free entrance experience is
something Bungie has put a lot of time
into making sure it was a thing and I
don't think that's something they're
just gonna completely remove now maybe
it's just a different experience go do
some strikes go do some crucible here's
a gambit here's a quick basic couple
story missions and then go but but I
doubt they do that because remember the
whole the whole creation of new light
their explanation was they don't want
you no guards to feel so separated so I
don't know maybe they do base campaign
you know today when shadow plots like we
visit that's the question yeah wait
that's question when shadow keep dropped
for new light were they able to do
shadow key missions no they can land on
the moon they can land on the Dreaming
city and go interact with the NPC and do
patrols rah but you quest didn't do
story you were just you couldn't do
story right hanging out there yes
FK oh yeah nah she's out yep menagerie
that's a that's going um yeah I guess
yeah he makes sense then because maybe
they is forsaken force a comes up as the
base I guess interesting they gotta give
them meaty stuff that I can't not give
them you know it's like I'm free yeah
it's like now for story it'd be like you
need some you need some transition and
this is where it would be weird cuz you
go cosmodrome you are a guardian get
your stuff fly out of here to the tower
cool tower okay from here if you go here
to forsaken and K dies is a weird trip
there's needs a buffer zone in there
it's not more yeah any like these
Commission's maybe I don't know maybe we
should like a recap they could do like a
recap kind of maybe it has like maybe
it's a recap video or story look at the
cam video get a storyboard you know of
where we are in this current thing and
then you can do it maybe on boredom that
way
Forge
I wouldn't picture them staying they
didn't mention them go they haven't
mentioned I know they're all on one
director cuz they could stay but if
scourge goes mm-hmm I can hit them right
cuz again I'm actually gotten right cuz
yeah they said the rains that will stay
the ridge there will be three raids
available in The Fault they did say then
yeah last week guards and new guy so
deep crown the scourge great Leviathan
the raid is all guys was it when excells
were made the new rape yeah which cleave
stone crypt yeah mmm loud Aloha behind
I'm very interested with that that'll be
very and we know and then we got one it
has a total different look to it and a
little bit like the little teaser trip
looks like nothing else
laughing else looks so cool in there
very very future II but like I don't
even know how to describe it looks
really cool it can't be getting one
activity changes its go sometimes gonna
be a lot of changes on the backend yeah
I will be I will be curious
gambit prime goes does reckoning go
hmm
maybe no no no that's a good question
that I'm gonna say no only because maybe
they tie in and do a new armor set or
making it or maybe it's some like
refresh because the drifters the
drifters part of this come to joy is
part of the yeah yeah so maybe it's like
new gambit
you know perfecting and reckoning maybe
they do a revamp of it without trying to
kill you from every angle or bridge I
don't know but again we have a we all
have a lot of questions about we know
what stuff's going planet wise we don't
know every single activity that's
leaving yet and I don't think they've
stated that they may not know they may
they may not haven't decided completely
or they're just not ready to tell us
what they know and so I feel like we
just don't that ready yeah we don't know
they keep it up at the dog that's a fact
and the Travelers was totally fixed in
the new director huh
well we've definitely gone off on a bit
of a tangent I would say yes yes I
believe so I don't I don't even think
where we're supposed to be at currently
mostly were probably on banner um what's
coming I know I don't think we touch
that and um so yes we do have iron
banner and bonus Valor starting next
week that'll be Tuesday through June
30th through July 7th in the morning so
we've got a couple things we've got and
this is where that discussion came up
actually we'll be adding two repressed
weapons curating the weapon reward loop
pulled down to eight weapons so you've
got the forward path and fool's remedy
yeah all weapons listed below are
considered reissued and we'll have
season of arrival max and fusion caps
shining sphere swarm of the Raven pounds
of Eagle Knight of the flower testicle
or wing small criminally stagger forward
path and fool's remedy will also be
updated have two additional perks
specific to those specific Ironman
weapons you've got iron grip improves
stability at a cost of reload speed
which that one seems like the better of
the two I own gaze improves weapon
target acquisition at the cost of range
armor set not a bad one coming back kind
of a not a bad look to it I don't know
[ __ ] and now an apple we'll see and of
course an emblem they did wanna remind
skill based matchmaking has been
disabled for iron banner use here
connection and light level trusting very
very enjoyable being show us how this
one feels because now you have a light
level engaged and connection based I'm
gonna be sitting there with like four
kills and somebody's gonna have eighty
two gonna get it's gonna be interesting
crucible feels different out of you have
get a chance been in it a little
different man hello but I'm just curious
as to why out of banner why remove it
from am very curious on that because is
it banner supposed to be the technical
activity and you know it's kind of like
are you say trials light so to speak
where for power level and stuff so
because it didn't they only say this
season so it's like why
I don't understand the thought process
behind that yeah crucible feel different
or I like you getting smacked you know
I'm saying or you're smacking it's very
extreme that is yeah it's interesting
all the other question that this all
brings up yeah
born with a raven oh yeah let's get it
we're getting a reissues let's talk
about it and this is this was my like
I'm totally about the Sun setting till
you see this and if we're getting like
by have a swarm of the Raven I literally
looked I have a spike field prep swarm
of the Raven now swarm is turned into a
rapid fryer so it got changed so it's
not quite as good but still I have a
spike field prep ambitious assassin
probably not perfect last birth but
still pretty solid and now we're gonna
get the newer versions like you're
probably reading my its own but you go
first men yeah so team not wanting a
reissue was me you know there but um I
conceded Legendary's I could see the
letters you know what rushing up the
loophole you know get some new blood in
there alright fine you know and then I
figured this would be a way if things
were broken looking at you mando oh man
you know that they could get it out but
then I see this and actually even before
this shout-out to when you're playing
and you know I'm gonna tell you right
now my favorite scouting game one of my
favorite PvE weapons good way is a Night
Watch Night Watch Scout rapid hit multi
kill cliff I have that one too baby
but it's older yeah you're still gonna
happen to play no I got the new one too
I got the exact same look down look down
Oh what's this snipe watch again what a
new outwit you know the icon and no new
perks so I'm like alright it's the same
gun that I grind it for then now you
gonna make me
go free earn with nothing new about it
Bungie we gotta talk fair we gotta talk
what what is this yeah what is it the
whole purpose of this was to freshen up
the loot pool now I get it
what one or two I'm not alright I'm
gonna let you slide Nightwatch I see you
a couple other ones I see you alright
Yuri you got a little new icon okay I
don't like it when I see you
yes well a full slew of iron banner
waving back from Millie's dagger like I
have I have a crap load that I probably
haven't even got of or rings Maul say
how many up guys brah 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
mmm way too many already not arguing
then but mmm somewhere in there probably
have an autoloading holster oh yeah you
know field prep demel it whatever reason
become I've got it wrong
I've got it for some options what yeah
remember the GOG world we used to form
the swarming rim with swarming Raven was
the thing when it was whole thing yeah
yeah yes pike yeah so is like I mean I'm
looking over talons of the eagle that's
like it's a scout rifle and I'm like I
don't even care about it but the time
was actually a towns disco you're right
but what do I have I have outlaw rampage
and I have moving targets in moment with
like basically max range on it
so I'm like I got a PDE I got a PvP role
and right here looking at mine not
carrying forward and I'm going to look
at another loophole of the exact same
weapon or I gotta go in a shorter amount
of time in one week not in the course of
years to try and get said role but I've
already got and this is a problem I from
weapons sunsetting if you take it out
and we're like hey reuse you a bunch
like not reissue but introduce a bunch
of newer weapons like we got six new
weapons this season and again the fall
maybe telling this maybe the band-aid
buffer season but if this is a telling
sign of things to come it's an issue
that's an issue it's an issue yeah you
can't you can't do that you can't tell
the base that this is why we're doing it
we gotta get really good
into power creep but we heard power
creep you know this is why it has to
change
I know you're not gonna like this and
then you slippin this in and I'm just
like this is not it this is not gonna go
well shout out the port a/c who I know
me and him went at it a little bit on
the let the Sun set it dig but I concede
it you don't say and he's finally giving
it up he's like no I agree like this was
his fear because the people who are on
this side our biggest fear was stuff
like this
how is 1g going to handle it's the next
execution yeah and right now we're
between seasons but you cannot again
time investment respect the players time
we've all grinded out these weapons
fought these weapons for perfect rolls
to get it again and then on time what
makes it bad is you're not giving new
perks at least if they were different
perks that could be acquired now I know
forward path in that sidearm or getting
iron gays or whatever this new thing
okay great you know I'm saying like what
two perks and Ohio that's what one of
the new purposes ones - like 40 range
it's a huge dump on range and or - 20
range plus 40 target are either way but
I'm like and it's on an auto rifle we're
ranges large so ya know this is and this
again like uh who said it
oh my darlin then they need to do a
weapon showcase for the fall if they
want to just dispel fears about Sun
setting and this may have been again the
band-aid of the final season of this
content before they do the huge
introduction but right now you got a lot
of people that are unhappy because if
you if you keep doing this if you're
like hey we're bringing in six weapons
and I'm bringing back twelve old ones
and I'm like no way it's gotta be like I
could I want twelve to two I want the
right I mean for all has to be huge fall
has to be like that's why anyway 3040 I
need a crap ton of weapons but see him
Jevon you can do like eight and maybe
two little ones here like truth-teller
coming back like that one you know what
kind of okay with that because I hadn't
learned in a while that was literally
year one nature of the beast like you do
a couple of those like that
three years old fine they were they were
year one they had static rules now we
got random sets that make sense
announcer that was in drifter buggies me
cuz I haven't got the duplicate roll and
mine's already good I got a shout-out
else um this is my issue should be a way
to superimpose your gob role into the
seat if they're gonna be the same and
you got that day me I think someone hit
up on her confusion almost there talking
about yeah bro you you you come on like
you can't just disrespect that you don't
think about the master cause man think
about all that brah we put work in we've
got time for blood pain many many a
nightfall ordeal was done with these
weapons
we gotta respect you know so yeah again
the only way they make this right is
come September I better see like an 80%
ratio of new stuff and this represents
that 20% you know cuz I do it this is
the only thing I do underside ooh
understand archetype stuff there's gonna
be certain archetypes that if you remove
everything will have will be very weak
to none but they got a handle it right
they got to show us cuz did this right
here remix in the same food you gave us
bingo flaperon yeah it's and I mean I
think we have we we all came to that
point exotics and they're big they're
special at some point you know year six
some of those may need to fall off but
we'll see
mm-hmm but we kind of settled like
they're staying legendaries take him out
if you're gonna bring him in and have
this bigger cycle but if it's just like
I can go through my collection of
weapons and be like these twelve are
coming back I'm like what about the ones
that I held onto yeah not that hmm go
ahead but not gonna say in their defense
I did see someone complain I believe on
Twitter to dmg and said bro you've got
to give us a way to rearm you know
impose these roles that we've already
had and transform them into the new
version since they're exactly the same
and he did give us the classic line that
the team is looking into it but at least
he acknowledged it you know saying that
that was mounting because yeah this this
is a hot button
topic very hot you know saying we
grinding out here and if you're gonna do
this especially if you're not
introducing new perks new features to
these guns you have you have to give us
a way to infuse it so he moved that
forward instead of regrind it's a
disrespect to the is he isn't disrespect
to the note that says how many kills you
have with PvE in and BB if I say go
figure come back I'm kind of lose my
mind oh you won't lose it you lose it
bro be like bring it back go figure
okay I literally had a god roll for
40,000 kills then I got a slightly
better one in still truck tucked with
forsaken on there but yeah if there's a
go figure that's got a right
what would the fall what would beyond
light I wonder what their little icons
gonna be from yeah yeah there's a beyond
light go figure dust in the air yeah
yeah bro but here's the thing to at
least see where they got a pass is
remember when they brought last hope and
interference and all that back new perks
cuz now interference has full court this
that right that's hold adds to get that
smoker that's what they supposed to be
doing like we're supposed to have though
that's what nobody said nothing when
last hope came back in there for
everybody if you look at it those two
weapons are highly sought after oh yeah
multi kill on lemon and Internode's
begin for more spike spike I said I'm
like I'm loving it now you've you've
reintroduced this old weapon but now
you've give it a new flavor and now
we're cool with somebody I've done I
can't with you Rico I kid out you did
not say that Rico
you are a fool actually I said you might
be good isn't it adaptive no I don't
think it's rapid-fire edge yeah edge is
still adaptive I have I have a perfect
edge yeah and that'll piss me off
because I've seen a thousand I narrowed
it down to the one that I wanted but if
you have to make me go so yeah that mmm
I don't know
it's I mean said for any second I'm not
trying to be debbie downer but I sadly
expected this one they seem to talk
about bringing back chats actually
moving fast
Oh
the one weapons and content if they
retired my weapons stuff that's
perfectly fine do not give me those
weapon back so the little no part
changes or give me something those
terrible iron banner / yeah and that's
the name to is what worries me is and I
said this before when I saw the perks
for iron banner mmm-hmm the ones cool
getting Astra stability so have a reload
cost that's an exchange I'm okay with
but if you go target acquisition for a
big chunk range hold on I gotta go to
let GG to see how big that it actually
yeah it's it's it's it's like since 40
40 yup take I'm gonna say like it's a 40
yeah it is yeah man black waiting shot
the interference facts like minus 40
plus 20 aim-assist but minus 40 on range
and it comes on in Auto rifle chars got
yeah 40 hit the auto rifle it comes on
as 50 range it's gonna take it down it's
gonna be and it's a 600 at that point
I'm gonna use a submachine gun cuz it's
faster exactly so like I understand
those perks and aim assists like okay so
it's gonna go up to 91 aim assist it's
already got 71 it's not that bad like
that trade high I don't want the curated
version you can't explain to me how
that's that good
what's the curity version
it's got dynamics away which is not bad
so you're gonna be laser-focused
you got dynamics lay iron gaze
armor-piercing red dot scope it's an
adaptive frame 600 rpm cool but yeah it
may be dynamics way really accurate
which even that got a boost which people
are enjoined but if you throw iron gaze
on there I don't want it now you can get
iron grip on it which I'll take then
it's gonna truly be a laser with dynamic
sway but I don't want it sly they one of
the perks they introduced I don't want
yeah I gotta get or I shot the press
californium feet to the fire he said
that's what he said that would be it it
hasn't happened I think that's the
biggest thing we're told one thing and
we're seeing another preach and this
shot the Dom he said World of Warcraft I
what you think would know what you think
about this he has been around since 2004
has found a way to stream almost 20
years of content while maintaining a 20
gigabyte install there's legit no excuse
but deadly to to be 100 Gig plus and
taking away combat content just for the
sake of making room or they gotta figure
it out would you say would you say I was
gonna say the size and textures of this
game are gonna be a little more detailed
than world because yeah higher fidelity
so that's what most your size comes from
period mm-hmm
when it comes to the size of the game
Call of Duty seems to manage it but
again I don't know how their patches
work but the way they have to patch
destiny it's probably actually
PlayStation even being a PlayStation
person the copying file size there's
probably a limit or like can't do that
stuff anymore so yeah there are
technical issues for the size thing they
probably wish they didn't have to cross
that bridge but they do yeah but also at
some point it's it's weird and that's
why it's like again is it an engine is
that d3 is that this with the destiny
content vault but also do you really
want to go play IO but for deep for and
this is again where we've all said it
and I agree with like Dom mm-hmm 2004 to
now however 16 years that it's been
going on Bungie goes very and this is
what you said Bungie goes very hard to
make weapons feel special
and they have so many of them it is hard
to make new ones stand out or feel
unique or at least have a bit of their
own personality so world has so many
like boxes of stats that is a world
thing and I've said it too and you've
said it to me it is a box of stats yeah
like I grinded the hell out of something
that has it's a cool-looking thing in my
inventory screen it has really good
things than I grinded my heart out for
it
mmm but it's not quite as it's not as
hard to build it is a somebody draws a
smaller image not 3d and then it has you
pick your stats to make the thing good
and it can be sought after but they
mailed a 3d model unique sounds unique
reload animations for it it has to fit
in the archetype pool that they've got
already so this is why if you're taking
all of these things out you need to put
new stuff in but that's where we have to
see what their bandwidth is like now
which is the big key how much do you how
much capacity does that studio have to
make 50 new weapons for the fall 12 new
weapons for each season and not bring
all that much old stuff back that's the
key that is hard so yeah it's it's tough
and again these are my concerns this was
my only negative thing throughout the
beyond light stuff when we were told no
d3 me sticker with d2 this was my
concern at the end of the day you still
with that 2017 or whatever it was
engine that you debut and at some point
that engine is going to be archaic it is
good these limitations to it that's just
always that's just the way it is it's
the way gaming works and that's my only
concern
because as gaming gets better as the
next generation consoles come out you
know I'm saying and systems improve and
we still running around with that Toyota
age no just predatorial but I'm just
saying strong this is why man and this
is why you have shout to someone said
looks at but that's the crystal you look
at Bethesda games and they all have some
of the same bugs if you want fallout 76
there
some of the same bugs that exists in
every Fallout game because of the engine
in the way it's designed
and that's something you cannot get away
from so it's just like that's my concern
that's why ultimately I to me they say
in this now but ultimately we're going
to have to get to DP maybe it's just
they not ready to talk about it right
now because of scarlet kid again was too
big I just can't see how you keep this
engine five more years
same three she I mean three at least
three right cuz we got up where they
gave us beyond light I was the next one
scarlet witch witch queen witch queen
whatever and it was last one little I
guess lightful got at some point you got
to we got to changed engine good new
ties got a company car
you can't just be you gotta train with
you finally gonna get miles on it I
can't just keep replacing the brakes and
the stress and twelve out the little
scratch in the door and then you get you
got a traded in its it's seen it smiles
transmissions and out shot the frame is
gonna fall apart
whole are metaphors right now apparently
yeah a lot of car let it call right now
see what you got against my rav4 cocky
with your ass bro but it just said look
if you run in that rap with two hundred
thousand miles and you wondering why you
still having issues and maybe it's time
to start looking at the car dealership
maybe it's time to take a visit and see
how the no cause is moving out here
that's all of zebra we'll see that's my
concern I just hope you know we don't
get hampered too much you know yeah I'm
having this is like hey these are a few
fan favorites this is the final season
moments of triumph mm-hmm solstice of
celsus of heroes like all this is just
like this is a celebration of the past
years and they're like throwing
everything at you so you can take just
more things into the fall just the
reissues now hurt a little bit yeah and
if they're a telling sign of the fault
that truly will that's a discussion like
if I was sitting there doing the dado
thing and this is my little sheet of
paper I really I was like explain to me
why my Night Watch that I have in my
vault
can't work
if I get the new Nightwatch that is
exactly the same if there's different
parts if it has a different ability if
it stats may feel different I don't know
but if it's the same thing that just had
to get it again it's like a question
giorgos what if we start we boot up via
light and then when they break the food
out it's a 50/50 trade for weapons that
we've already had here's the Baltic
clasp offense again like what would you
do I would do it with you at with that
I'll think on that for a second but I
don't say what do you think about vault
coming back I mean are you excited to
get me I'm I'm Bob the rompers I'm
biased I'm too biased I cannot give you
an objective answer
I am completely clouded by them and what
what guns what does a caiman Forte says
I live in uh what's that word you always
use it but I talk about volt
rose-colored glasses thanks color they
started I I'm the wrong listen I am all
about fall vault is a nostalgic piece
for me
we know how I feel about its ranking and
in the hierarchy the pantheon of rage
you know how I feel and vault has some
crazy weapons crazy weapons like if
favoring it comes back I'll tell you
this they're gonna get sales off on
histology alone you know I'm saying yes
I mean I'm sure well yeah yep Jeff for
that just the Fate breaker just for um
Olli diva talk about it um big big
fusion boy what's what means oh god it's
been too long
yeah what come on help me out big big
blizzard football
hey what about blinking on this day I'm
gonna you're sayin vex mythoclast story
back smith the class but if nothing
minutes on a your legendary exotic
salvia mythic thank you gosh t get bra
day they got that you know um I will say
this I do like the idea of this raid
remix one per season if it be a map the
madly per year by the way per year per
year excuse me per year that's right if
it fits because I go front I am I think
a great marketing tool is come score six
hours keeps calling it scarlet which
what is it which Queen which Queen keeps
calling I mean working which scarlet
keep what you think yeah that's what it
is it scarlet keep Becky so which Queen
expansion you can't say you can't tell
me II they throw that and you see that
taking King the take a cake spell I've
already called that you know said I'm
saying
dreadnought is the rehab destination
because we get a new one wrong but I
could also see them expanding the game
with an old one so if I rewind they
repaint dreadnought and bring back
taking hang prevail and it makes sense
because it's related to ting in or
exhaust a buffoon they whole like ties
just I'm already yesterday I'm already
expecting now it's going straight up
yeah yeah you had the new threat what
they would you know Sabbath dual now do
whole game weapons the kv-4 add orange I
do hope the weapons that come from there
that auto-rifle Barry get massively
better that hand cannon sucked so bad
Shaw is terrible all of Kobe King weapon
that told you taking machine not good
and you had no vapor that I liked those
two felt good the rest was okay that was
okay
Scout was okay yeah do don't have to
yeah but yeah nothing like the some of
those were so trashes raid weapons I'm
like what do you do in d c-- and that
would be cool that's why said a is a
little excitement with the final yes
that's it's not defies of Yaz me let's
go and I can't remember the machine gun
the big ugly quick Willem Willem
terminus yep yep enemy that's it
you know sable arm
there is a little excitement to have the
vault weapons to the taken king weapons
with the new perks the weapon model
stuff like that there's a little
excitement a chance for them to be
better and if have them kind of spit out
in some cool archetypes I think it's a
pot that has potential to be cool but
it's the I think it's a great marketing
tool you just did being about to do two
taken Queen before you dead you know we
gotta take it back you for would you
fight Oryx again though in a remix right
yeah I think it's okay it's like a
timepiece it's a it's a nostalgic piece
you know I think there's Assad at least
that's how I picked they bought me when
he mentioned volts coming back
yeah I feel whiskey JWoww I was like an
experience like vault in glass but with
like champions and stuff in there things
of that nature they said basic right but
it's like if I kill a Theon again is
like we're going back in time to see
what I mean is that how do you cuz a lot
of Lee yeah that's what you know how do
you I don't think it's a I don't think
it's cannon the vibe I'm getting is
almost like a age of triumph kind of
thing just like you know experience this
destiny one raid remade into destiny -
yeah here you go
yeah I play mechanics and yeah g2 weapon
yeah hash whatever cuz you can't explain
it narrative Lee you kid we've done this
beat this there's no way
yeah that didn't explain it that beard
shout the whiskey says I'm honestly
starting to think they should have just
made a new game they need a new engine
anyways they should have made a new
expansion as a new game like it was
originally planned all the d2 content
weapons could stay and be a separate
game with sell and purchase they could
continue to sell all the d2 stuff and
put d3 or whatever in a new engine
something feels like they're milking
their insufficient tech wow this game
these work of - Wow okay and I think
this is where the fall will be telling
us - what they're keep using bandwidth
whatever they can put out what them is a
studio without the help of Activision or
hi moon or anything else right the paint
it really depends how many weapons can
you make for a fall expansion how you
know how many story missions do we get
how many new strikes I mean we're losing
a lot of stuff mm-hmm
I don't expect it all to come back in
right but yeah it's like how how much we
get until they're ready for the d3
moment I think that's exactly it's like
they're trying to make the most of their
current situation right but yeah as
whiskey said it's like D the d3 does
have to we've all said that you me we've
said that two times that I think it has
to happen at some point because of all
the limitations because of whether it be
cross play whether it be next-gen
ray-tracing tech like if they want to be
like hey here we're in old school you
know D
- you know action MMORPG or you can go
boot up your PS 5 and experience of ray
tracing and destiny - and just be blown
away and how gorgeous that HDR lighting
looks like you try and run HDR through
destiny - right now I was like I mean PC
has it but is like I still just wonder
like some of that stuff may be already
in there in the background that may be
stuff to me building for you know when
the new consoles come out I have its but
yeah the the the reissuing begs the
question of how much can they do for
each expansion and how and again I'll
break everybody if I ever say hey what
if there wasn't a fall expansion right
now and d3 launched with beyond light
what if we didn't get a fall and Beyond
light launched in 2021 but that was on
d3 new platform and they didn't do
anything but make new stuff for a year
quietly and go BAM 2021 I witness
so do d2 stuff just like enjoy what you
got we'll do iron banner and trials
rotates every week in the weighty ones
going right now and then d3 lunches in
2021 lake and that would give them time
to just say hey this is maintenance the
whole studio make new stuff focus go I'm
not gonna be popular right now cuz I
would cosign that whole movement yeah
I'm gonna be honest with you bro
you know what disgusted me I'm gonna
live you know really disgust me to look
at shout out to Luke we know we love him
um when Lupo said so with all these
changes that it up and accept the magic
words he was waiting the hey and he says
so what about them dedicated servers
though and he said no don't like the
fact Lee I was just like my heart son
I'm not gonna lie it crushed me I was
just lying and I get it because let's be
real the way their system works it's a
very unique peer-to-peer system nobody
broke it down one time and to me that is
structurally tie to the engine again
just looking for another DEATH just
looking making observations that looks
like that's tied to your engine that
looks like that's the part of the core
of your game play so my thing is that
can't be changed with this engine you
have to make it decrease because they
remember they raved about this new
system Wendy too was lost they were like
look this is what we improved from d1
this cannot be done in d1 now because we
got this tremendous system yada yada
yada right so we're stuck with this I
don't know how they're going to address
the cheating let's be real let's call
the elephant in the room how they going
just achieve with PvP with this engine
you know it is I don't know what they
work on behind the scenes with steam so
you got that and again there's still
things they're not gonna be able to run
from with the old engine and then
correct me if I'm wrong chat or II don't
they is it destiny using unreal
then link so what do they use it they
like they use it a custom inside your
engine is what they've called it forever
the big what I'm very sure that's what
I've heard it called is the tiger engine
and so if the tiger huh could you
imagine if it was unreal engine five
room or something I mean something they
have to rebuild that from the ground up
and steal our Tigers
yeah and I think part of
hmm the destiny to gun play is so so
unique so the way they feel the way it
is and that may be one of those honestly
this would be a fun question ask them 20
years from now feel like it looms like
Luke being like you know late 50s or
something like that but our age as well
mm-hmm I honestly would wonder it and
says like when they Heather's you know
doesn't matter it's out the eye-full
tell all book whatever it's like me yeah
we need they made the guns so good and
perfect in their engine
I honestly wonder if somebody's sitting
there be like hey see if you can
recreate this in like unreal and I
honestly wonder if they can't yeah
they've can't maybe it's just so custom
it's custom whatever the animation and
it's like I feel like because that is
one of the special sauces of destiny
that's why so many be ash still stick
around is like the way the guns feel and
kind of the way the heads explode but
that's a different thing but the way
they feel is
I don't I wonder how hard that is to
replicate yeah you come you could be
onto something because um guess I had no
idea maybe it's no I mean it could very
well be that they have I just think they
have such a unique combination of
systems that mesh that it just worked
for them and maybe they can't replicate
that gun I mean in case in point you
know why you may be really onto
something is I'm a huge Mass Effect fan
right
Mass Effect one through three was done
on unreal and that game look phenomenal
it played phenomenal say what you want
to say about Mass Effect 3 than anyway
I'll get to that but as far as the game
as far as the visual fidelity in the
engine the way it move then hydrometer
comes out they are picked up by ETA and
they're forced to put it on frostbite
yep raaah the memes they had had
animations it was horrible
so you could be right it could be a
situation that good old tiger is what
they know and that's what they're
comfortable with and in that case I
won't fight but you need to make Tiger
to Dan that was got a tease of them
updating things with we got to see the
almighty get exploded so they pulled
their first laughs event and they
continued would you rather the feel of
Hawkmoon or but the new engine without
it wow I don't understand it straight
off there what is he yes no he would
like Hawkman's coming back in the fall
when I'd rather enjoy Hawkmoon with the
field that I know and love from D one
that I really enjoyed the feel of that
gun or would I take beyond light in a
new engine I would honestly rather
probably have the new engine one it's a
reissue let me see I had my time in the
Sun with that and it has been set to the
side no but that's the question there's
like what if I just feel what if what if
we get a new issue engine but it doesn't
feel it's no you're right you it's gotta
feel like destiny and there's I think
one of the pieces that they have to if
they ever go to either destiny three in
Tiger 2.0 or unreal right whatever they
go to they have to make sure it still
feels the way they want it to because
your hairs obey
still absolutely based on two things
numbers which is too weird things to be
based on cuz they don't make sense
together
they're very heavily based on numbers of
data and they're based on feel right and
those who don't make sense together but
ya know II you you nailed it I I think
you're right I think as much as I want
that new engine it's gotta be the new
Tiger engine and I don't know if they're
in any position already probably do it
which is another reason probably why
they wanted to break free from
activision because we know activision is
on cadence activision is like you know
every three years we given you this
bread and you gonna pump out this this
this and this and if you don't meet
those requirements we don't listen
there's a reason activision let them go
let's not act like bandages sat there
and they propria independence fact
activision also in their defense
probably said to themselves it's not
worth the investment or the hassle based
on the speed in which they can i cannot
make content so it's a mutual split
remember active if the if bungee was
doing everything activision wanted them
to do they would not be let go
alright that's just a fact it's so and
then we know bungee also for that their
cells they like look we don't want to be
controlled we want our own feeling we
don't want certain things implemented
and that's that so i also i think we
knew that they probably weren't ready
for d3 anyway let's just call it what it
is by themselves without vicarious
without her no they're not ready for d3
right now that thus the statement let's
get that which I commend them get in
front of it say it's not coming right
now
staying with d2 but at some point
whether it be three years yeah five
years so I think player should be you
have these three expansions they
announced they picture and they're like
okay how long does it take to build an
engine build a new game and build all of
the things three years with whatever
they're working on right now that
potentially is like this is the public
plan that you see one two three years of
expansions right underneath that that
internally they have they're building
deep they have to they have to ale
deeper half dude there's no way hey I
know how they gonna get around it to
they he was Kia about say Luke was key
about not saying three as a number but
what you do is you I guess World of
Warcraft destiny blah blahs destiny yeah
destiny blah blah
that's the new version without putting a
number on ya understand you're not to
meet you got to do it but I is like
sorry you know trying to talk some
people are saying the like hey if we get
a darkness subclass in year for darkness
sub less or some more darkness stuff in
your 5 something else in your six you
have the light and the dark light fall
happens and then potentially do you have
your MMO light versus dark like and you
have to make a new character for d3
because you can pick the light side of
the dark side and it is truly like is
that how they they do that and one other
person is saying - and I heard this
rumor somewhere I can't remember where
if it's where I'm thinking of I'm not
gonna say it potentially the reason
they're taking so much out of the game
is potentially they're working on some
newer engine stuff and it's easier to
move some things forward to a new engine
same thing with the dungeon mm same
thing with the dungeon that's in the
game now that has to come out to come
back later okay potentially the fall
could be you know Tyger Tyger engine one
way for or whatever like you'll get some
updates to it and they remove it right
and while that stuff's out it can be
rehashed for whatever might come into
the new and then they actually have the
systems they chose like what's the set
of stuff that we can get done mmm and so
that's why it's the biggest chunk out
right so the question ball is an update
but again dedicated servers still kind
of sucks yeah the question just becomes
I guess if that's the case and I know we
move on we go for a while with it but
the question becomes one point love what
the question becomes you know can in
live service game in do it can you do a
full engine update and keep the game up
at the same time you know I'm Sam and
that's kind of it that's the tough
question mm-hmm I mean you take we have
the access to the API everybody does
with destiny item manager and Burrtec so
you have the data and if you can somehow
take said new engine still read read
data but use it in the new you know the
fancy scanned way potentially you could
because all they're gonna shut down
pash the client they're gonna patch the
servers but they're still gonna run my
character data that's buried somewhere
in a bungie server so if it reads all
that and pulls it into said new engine
maybe it maybe it can't again I'm so not
a developer not even remotely but
potentially it's like the data is
sitting there right which is also really
annoying to me why my vault can't be
bigger that's a separate issue entirely
the the data just sits there give me
give me another 500 lines on your your
data list there for my fault to be
bigger but all that being said yeah
maybe that is a case maybe is there a
point where Xbox one and s's and the ps4
regulars don't run destiny two or three
years from now and they only updated the
the mid fret the refresh when do they
start leaving old tech behind those are
that's not different that's not because
Xbox already alluded it after like a
year for two years then it's gonna be
they're leaving at s and basically the
Lockhart and the X via the Xbox series X
is going to replace the X Box one X and
the Lockhart is going to replace the
Xbox one s that's happening it's just
that they do on a smooth transition with
the smart delivery stuff in the
beginning for like maybe one to two
years but there will be a cut-off it's
just like anything else but again like
where does destiny make that cutoff
they're gonna have to they're gonna have
to at some point yeah that's like hey we
want things to look prettier you know
these things have like HDR and they're
checkerboarding and all those things
that they can do an old-school stuff you
guys are spinning up but like again
that's the point
that's the stuff to watch like those
type of decisions that get made a little
bit farther apart to shout out to um
dizzy if Unreal Engine 5 can be upgraded
to yeah absolutely at Forte he says
they'll take the game offline like fort
and I did when they transition to the
game the new engine up there it's
possible and we we have seen them this
in their defense remember when they had
that some game breaking situation and
Mehmedi had to they had to we go back
into their backup data archives and yeah
we everybody lost currency everybody
loved currencies yes that was an
impressive thing so that means obviously
the the data backups one point they said
that they were actually scared without
the first time they actually had to test
their own so yeah it could have been
potentially disastrous so yeah I think
that on
yeah what say I did you under something
they would um therefore you have to take
it down for like a day if they indeed
plan to do it now I hope that's the case
I just want a new engine you can't be
coming in in with there's some old
busted Tigers five years that tiger
engine come on man you know saying he's
trying to step it up you know get get
him looking right out here that's all
I'm saying
oh yeah I'm I mean if you guys haven't
seen I probably said it in my video
black lives matter pin you can pre-order
that the new prep imaging you can
pre-order that so I got both of those
coming
check out the Bungie store all profits
on both of those pins go to very good
causes on both ends so again they do all
that stuff for oh it's such good causes
so definitely go check those two out
please check out the only few I got you
ordered already you know you get the
emblem already right yep
yes I got it I'm not gonna go dig my
yeah it's good emblems of fire both of
them a fire and I'm saying so yeah I got
them to match bottom a little warlocks
the same avoid you got the LGBT g1 and
then I got the balm - all black laughs
dad enjoying from a solar with the
yellow got the outfits to match I'm out
here check me out
uh but yeah I was like I know we talked
about a whole random bunch of stuff I
know we started serious and it's
important stuff to cover mobs light but
somehow we fill up two hours every time
getting off left and to wait like
there's there's literally nothing in
here besides I talked I told you the
TLDR it's like the world is on fire and
iron banner is coming back and we still
go for two hours so how we do it's the
last word oh we gotta get the last word
in these things and yeah things to get
the last word
it's like an out by the way I know we
forgot to mention because it was going
on next week or last week gcx finished
with all yay Bungie getting $800,000
lupo get 960 and the whole combined
effort this time six million dollars
going to st. jude's from gcx mm-hmm six
million plus that is that is some
special yeah and honestly I cannot wait
for Guardian con next year because it
has been it would be today it would be
tomorrow shout out that we had a
speaking of Teddy he's in teddy but we
had on the show last night yep like he
said it hit him - we like we had all
been chilling together anyone a big dope
just to see a lot you know I'm see
thanks to you guys to chat you know you
guys have been helping us to promote
this thing and and just to see you I
mean 50 60 all in here right now like
super humbled to see and um you know
just to meet people not a name to the
face now and a lot of people I know
we're going you know and we would've got
a chance to even jar of said he was good
like everything many guest it I know and
it's a making a trip across the pond and
stuff like that any other come in yeah
facts you know I'm saying so it's just
like yeah is is it would have been so
much fun and I can't wait for the world
to go back to normal so we can get back
to our cons get back to Orlando get back
to the the Orlando Leviathan that I call
it has the full rate experiencing the
full ratings video yeah I've been to the
rosy shade over that's the little via
Tim bro you don't even need to leave
that but it has everything Golf Course
pool whatever it is you monkey they even
fit a convent multiple convention
centers inside there you got three
reads and it's in there three Reds get
the basement you gotta you got the
penthouse yeah you got a mom we got it
all man so yeah it's gonna be lit man 20
21 you bounce back strong me he will be
in the building lighting as long as some
of these states get their act together
Florida's one of those yeah backs but
yeah hopefully a year from now we're in
a better place maybe we can see if a
vaccine come God who knows but cross our
fingers something like that might happen
needs to be done right but hopefully
that's maybe a possibility down the road
eventually but
yeah I was like I think that's all we
got for the podcast we got to do a
wrap-up before we go guys um for mine I
just kind of want to get mine out there
first on Sunday for those of you guys
who are out here listening from about
for Central Time
it's gonna be 5 p.m. to 1 a.m. and
please come keep me alive during that
one a.m. section because I got to get up
early the next morning in like 4 hours
so it's gonna be a rough morning I'm
gonna crash Monday afternoon mm-hm but
I'm going to do be doing a stream with
the karmis revenge group they've been
doing one all week I'm gonna close down
their week least their their week-long
stream Athan and it's all supporting
black lives matter so nice everything
donated in there that will get up links
and just kind of doing that to help
support black lives matter so come in
there hang out with me trying to figure
out what I'm gonna be doing I might be
working on solo and prophesy we'll see
but definitely come hang out in there so
that will be again Sunday that will be
what is that 28th and it's gonna be a 5
p.m. central time to 1 a.m. Central time
I'll be closing down their full week so
definitely come hang out with me on that
one other than that you guys know where
to find me it might be playing last of
us destiny stream and twitch Twitter
YouTube find me in all the places it's
been awesome I know I went first but
that's what I wanted to get out there so
what's your weekend hold sir yeah I'm a
well first of all again love first of
salute to the chested everybody got a
lot of important topics talked about get
your pins y'all get dad make him dad
make him do exercises - that was funny
oh boy yeah so Luke get those pins y'all
bungees out here doing good things I got
my first one I'm just waiting for the
blacklivesmatter joint you know I'm
saying so I could complete the trifecta
got the emblems out there well yeah man
it was good show on
for me already no outlaw Cognito on
twitter um i'll or podcast on youtube no
guest this week cuz cog needs to break
introducing people i put great care into
these introductions and sometimes it's
just cool to just you know talk with
your fellas talk with my brethren talk
to Iran last word without necessarily
you know giving everyone the greatest
introduction since I'll give my voice a
little rest until next week but um not
so this week we'll definitely it's gonna
be no guest but we could have some on
fire topics man so look out for that
probably gonna talk about that cyberpunk
probably gonna talk about the halo
infinite um T's and oh he's got to do it
as we see here the last where we support
fitness and which are donations to the e
bonta's channel you could make him do
things like this you can make him do
push-ups sit-ups look at the impressive
form elbows are locked out right now
this is classic vintage Fitness is the
key to well-being y'all like way C to
sit up if you were to set up side UBS it
right now go let that pass we gonna let
that cook Ovid bellies out here so we
gonna let that pass well anyway yes
there we go make them do the sit-ups
y'all put y'all use that 5,000 I may
redeem might get him out there now look
at this tremendous form y'all look he's
got the knees top everything is going
back look look crunching to the top see
that right there's a science show when
you're in the gym you want to crunch all
the way to the top hit the knees look at
the posture this is how you do the sit
ups y'all this what you got to do man if
you want to get back in shape we here at
the last word support fitness and at any
time if you want e to hit that and give
you that easy that's it they give you
that proper form that's what we do baby
this is premium entertainment right now
after last work you heard he at first my
man Wow check this out yard now we are
at a record 30 to 40 push-ups yo the
guns are gonna be off I'm tell you right
now you get you get the outer head of
the tricep with this look look at look
at the form you get that you get your
bicep work going on look at the pot I'm
telling you this is prime stuff during a
pandemic we're happy to provide this
service to you all free of charge
basically
this is hard work because I can just
count the tea all day you better you
better let me show y'all behavior until
next week and we reach out back at the
last word Fitness channel but anyway
I've got Itoh you already know what it
is look if you want those fitness tests
my man he got you man he's a beast out
here big deal yeah there's there's a few
you guys who could just ruin me I didn't
even warm up that was funny can I do
some squats squats I'll do even some
squat holds I got laid that's the SMM
get my boy out here babies beast it
Chris this is your fault this is your
fault Chris to any 30k you got 30k all
check this I here we go here we go now
we're not doing the weighted look look
at the posture look at the posture no
jump come on no jumping lunges par 5 we
got to be nice you got to be nice no
jumping lunge look at the good form you
going low and I can't say the word but
it's behind the grass is another term we
use in the gym but it's to grass so
that's what we doing right here normally
we would have exactly I can't say
there's a family-friendly show I can't
say so textbook fundamental see what you
do is you keep the arms forward the back
is straight nice and low dead eagle
objects that is a very high difficult
move you let me explain the arms
extended tremenda pause look at the low
center of gravity look at the bit okay
he's flossing right now that's a person
who's lower half is all point alright
it's like you know not anybody could do
this it's all about the fitness baby we
get bit right we get you jacked up
before you play that desk you gotta be
jacked up it's God
[Music]
hilarious okay yeah well I'm waking
everybody on video enjoyed this one and
one more thing yes what I gotta breathe
so what I want to make sure we do is you
guys know mixer actually got merged into
Facebook gaming some people stayed there
some people come back to twitch that
being said mmm I want to raid a previous
mixer person oh I went over which when
we get done oh we're gonna go here oh
fish after this so go hang out with her
send her some love as for me I'm gonna
drink some water here y'all yes yeah
yeah don't you study ain't no tear for
me wishful thinking don't you start take
10,000 points to get kognito in here you
gonna have to start donating like bits
and stuff to see that man go you guys
are lucky I'm worth points I'm gonna
have to turn these points higher you
guys have too many I'm gonna make this
worth 10,000 another five I got like a
gazillion oh yeah thanks bags moved up
so you know I like what you're doing got
it - got to dab go a couple boy dab in
slow
well yeah we got an arm salute for the
people who are on now you know we know
the situation we're mixer you know going
over to Facebook game in well going over
to twitch you know I'm saying let's
let's definitely I think the other
should go in some places depending on
where they were so mmm absolutely
alright so Sunday 5 p.m. central come
right back here hang out with me
twitch.tv slash Avant is supporting
black lives matter all night long till I
fall asleep hopefully not in the chair
and hang out on stream guys I'm gonna
send the raid over so we're gonna wrap
this thing up episode 109 Oh started
somber
definitely important stuff finished with
insanity thank you guys very in here for
episode 109 it has been the last word